for the past few lectures we've been
discussing the structure set Edition and
which culminated in the proof of
Freeman's theorem so this was a pretty
big and central result in additive
combinatorics which gives you a complete
characterization of sets with small
doubling today I want to look at a
somewhat different issue also related to
a set of small doubling but this time
we're want to have a somewhat different
characterization of what it is a mean
for a set to have lots of additive
structure so in today's lecture we're
always going to be working in an abelian
group let me define the following
quantity given sets a and B we define
the additive energy between a and B to
be denoted by E and B so a and B are
subgroups subsets subsets of this
arbitrary abelian group
so a of a and B is defined to be the
number of tuples a1 a2 b1 b2 where a1 a2
or elements of a and B 1 B 2 are
elements of B such that a1 plus b1
equals 2 a2 plus b2 okay so the additive
energy is the number of quadruples of
these elements where you have this
additive relation and we would like to
understand sets with large additive
energy so intuitively if you have lots
of solutions to this equation in your
sets then the sets themselves should
have lots of internal additive structure
it was a different way of describing an
inner structure and we like to
understand how does this way of
describing and the structure relate to
things we've seen before namely small
doubling
when you have not two sets but just one
sent slightly easier to think about we
just write e of a meanie of a comma a
and these objects are analogous to four
cycles in graph theory right because if
you think about you know this expression
here in a KD graph let's say over F Q
then this is the description of our four
cycle you go around four steps and you
come back to where you started from
so these objects are the analogs are
four cycles and we already saw in our
discussion of quasi randomness and also
elsewhere
there are four cycles play important
role in graph theory and likewise these
additive energies are going to play
important role in describing sets with
additive structure ok consider the
following quantity we're going to let R
sub a comma B X to be the number of ways
to write X as a plus B ok so R sub a
comma P of X it's a number of ways I can
write access a plus B where it comes
from big a low B comes from Big B then
reinterpreting the formula off there we
see that the additive energy between two
sets a and B they're simply sum of the
squares of a R sub a comma B as X ranges
over all elements of the group you only
need to take X in the Sun set a plus B
okay so the basic question like when we
discussed additive combinatorics in the
sense when we discussed sets of small
doubling there we asked you know if you
have a set a of a certain size how big
can a plus a be here let's ask the same
if I give you set a of a certain size
how big or how small can the additive
energy of the set be what's the most
number possible number of additive
quadruples was the least possible number
of additive quadruples there are some
trivial bounds just like in the case of
some sets so what are some trivial
bounds on one hand by taking a1 equal to
a2 and b1 equal to p2 we see that the
energy is always at least the square of
the size of a on the other hand if I fix
three of the four elements then the
fourth element is determined so the
upper bound
there's cube the size of a and you
convince yourself that you know except
up to maybe a constant factors this is
the best possible general upper and
lower bound similar situation with some
sets where you have lower bound linear
upper bound quadratic which is the sign
with additive structure so if you have
lots of additive structure you have high
energy so this range is when you have
lots of additive structure and we would
like to understand what can you say
about a set with high additive energy
well what are some examples of sets with
high additive energy it turns out that
if you have a set that has small table
then automatically it implies large
additive energy so in particular
intervals or G ApS or large subsets of G
ApS all these examples that we saw in
fact these are all the examples coming
from freeman's theorem also in arbitrary
groups you can have subgroups or so all
of these examples have large additive
energy okay so let me I'll show you the
proof this in a second it's not hard but
the real question is what about the
converse so can you say much in the
reverse direction but first let me show
you this claim that small doubling
priced large additive energy well if you
have small doubling if a plus a is size
and most k times the size of a then it
turns out the additive energy of a is at
least the maximum possible which is a
cubed divided by K within a constant
factor of the maximum is pretty large if
you have small doubling then large
additive energy so let's see the proof
so you can often tell how hard a proof
is by how simple the statement is
although that's not always the case as
we've seen with some of our theorems
like clinickers inequality but in this
case it turns out to be fairly simple so
we see that R sub a comma a is supported
on a plus a so we use Cauchy Schwartz to
write okay so first we write the
additive energy in terms of the sum of
the squares of these arse
and now by cauchy-schwarz we find that
you can replace the sum of the squared
art by the sum of the RS but now the key
point here is that we take out this
factor coming from cauchy-schwarz which
is only a plus a so if the support size
is small we gain in this step but what
is the sum of ours I mean R of X is just
number of ways to write access little a
1 plus little a be a little a 2 so if I
sum over all X I'm just looking at
different two ways we're just looking at
ways of picking a word pair from a so
this last expression is equal to size of
a to the power 4 divided by a plus a and
now we use that a small doubling to
conclude that the final quantity is at
least a cubed divided by okay okay so so
we see small doubling implies large
additive energy so and this kind of
makes sense if you set doesn't expand
then there are many collisions of sums
and so you must have lots of solutions
to that equation up there but what about
the converse if I give you a set with
large additive energy mustn't
necessarily have small doubling let me
show you an example
so okay so large additive energy and
there's a implies small so consider the
following example where you take a set a
which is a combination it's a union of a
set with small doubling plus a bunch of
elements without additive structure so I
think a set with small doubling plus a
bunch of elements without a data
structure then it has large additive
energy just coming from this interval
itself energy water and cube what about
a plus a well for a plus a this part
doesn't that that's the part that
contributes right the part of this a
without a data structure and we see that
the size of a plus a is quadratic in the
size of a or so unfortunately the
converse fails so you can have sets that
have large additive energy and also
large doubling but you see the reason
why this has large additive energy is
because there is a very highly
structured and actively structures piece
of it right somehow we want to forget
about this extra garbage and that's part
of the reason why the converse is not
true so we would like a statement that
says that if you have large additive
energy then it must come from some
highly structured piece that has small
doubling and that is true and that's the
content of the pollak similarity cowards
theorem which is the main topic today
so the [ __ ] similarly cowers theorem
says that if you have a set so we're
working always in some arbitrary abelian
group if you have a set with large
energy then there exists some subset a
prime of a such that a prime is a fairly
large proportion of a and here by large
I mean up to polynomial changes in the
error parameters okay so this a prime is
such that a prime has small coupling you
have large additive energy then I can
pick out a large piece with small
doubling constant I only lose a
polynomial in the error factors so
that's the power of similarity cowers -
and you know it describes this example
up here any questions about the
statement so what I will actually show
you is a slight variant as a more
general statement where instead of
having one set we're going to have two
sets so here's our theorem version two
where now we have two sets again a beer
no I'm good knocking the writing any I'm
going to write it in this lecture but a
and B are always subsets of some
arbitrary abelian group a and B both
have sides at most N and energy between
a and B is large then the exists subset
a prime of a
P prime of P such that both a-prime and
b-prime are large fractions of their
parent set and such that a prime plus B
prime is not too much bigger than n it's
not so obvious why the second version
implies the first version you can say
well take a and B to be the same but
then the conclusion gives you possibly
two different subsets a prime and B
prime but the first version I only want
one subset that has small tumbling so
fortunately the second version does
imply the first version okay so let's
see why the second version implies the
first version because if we okay so
consider K so there's a tool that we
introduced early on when we discussed
fragments theorem and this is the Russa
triangle inequality so the spirit Arusha
triangle inequality is it allows you to
relate go back and forth between
different some sets and different sets
so by roots our triangle inequality if
we apply the second version with a
equals to B then and we pick out this a
prime and B prime then we see that a
prime plus a prime is at most a prime
plus V prime squared over B Prime
well this uses the as with and uses a
slightly stronger version that we had to
use clinickers lúcia key lemma to proof
but you can you can come up I mean
don't care about the precise lost in
polynomial factors you can also use the
basic whose a triangle inequality that
reduce a similar statement this is
easier to deduce so you have that and
now the second version tells you that
the numerator is a most pol EK and and
the denominator is well at least and
divided by polychaete remember over here
to get this hypothesis we automatically
have that the size of a and B are not
too much smaller than n or else this
cannot be true so putting all these
estimates together okay so these two
versions that they are equivalent to
each other the second version implies
the first second one is stronger
the first one is slightly more useful
they're not necessarily equivalent but
the second one is stronger any questions
alright so this is the power exam we're
ending our storm so the content of
today's lecture is to show you how to
prove this theorem
I'd remark about the naming of this
theorem so you might notice that these
three letters do not coming off a
medical water and the reason is that
this theorem was initially proof that
power can same ready
but using more involved method that
didn't give polynomials high pounds and
hours in has proof of some radius
theorem in his new proof of somewhere
nice theorem work good bounds he
required he looked into this theorem and
gave a new proof that resulted in these
polynomial type towns and it is that
idea that we're going to see today
what so this course is called graph
theory narrative combinatorics and the
last two topics in this course today
being Pollock similarity cowers and
tomorrow we're going to see some product
problem are both great examples of
problems in the additive combinatorics
where tools from graph theory play
important role in their solutions so
it's a nice combination of the subject
where we see both topics at the same
time so I want to show you the proof of
Pollock some reading hours and the proof
goes via a graph analogue so I'm going
to state for you a graphical version of
the Pollack's I'm already Coward's
theorem and it goes like this
if G is a bipartite graph between vertex
sets a and B and here a and B are still
subsets of the abelian group we define
this restricted subset a plus sub G of B
to be the set of sums where I am only
taking sums across edges in G
so in particular is G is the complete
bipartite graph and this is the usual
subset but now I may allow G to be a
subset of the complete bipartite graph
so only taking some but not all of the
only taking yeah some of the sums but
not all of them the graphical version of
Pollock similarity cowers says that if
you have a and B B subsets of an abelian
group both having size at most N and G
is a bipartite graph between a and B
such that G has lots of edges as at
least n squared over K edges if the
restricted subset between a and B is
small so here we're not looking at all
the sums but a large fraction of the
possible pairwise sums if that sum set
has small size this is kind of like a
restrictive doubling constant then there
exists a prime subset of a B prime
subset of B with a prime and B Prime
both fairly large fractions of their
parent set and such that the
unrestricted some set between a prime
and B prime is not too large
okay so let me say it again so if ever
fairly dense so constant fraction
extensively a fairly dense bipartite
graph between a and B and B are subsets
of the abelian group then and such that
the restricted subset is small then I
can restrict a and B to subsets fairly
large subsets so that the complete sum
set between the subsets a prime and B
prime is small let me show you why the
graphical version of PSG implies the
version of PSG I stated up there
right so why do we care about this
graphical version well suppose we look
at so so we have all of these hypotheses
that's right policies up there
so let's write R to be R sub a comma P
so I don't have to carry these
subscripts all around what do you think
okay so I start with a and B up there
and I need to construct that graph G so
what should we choose as our graph let's
consider the popular sums so the popular
sums are going to be elements in the
complete song set such that it is
represented as a sum in many different
ways and we're going to take edges that
correspond to these popular sums so
let's consider bipartite graph G
such that a color be it's an edge if and
only a plus B is a popular son
okay so let's verify some of the
hypotheses so we're going to assume
graph PSG and let's verify the
hypothesis in graph PSG on one hand
because each element of s is a popular
sum if we consider its multiplicity we
find that the size of s multiplied by n
over 2k lower bounds the size of a times
the size of P if you think about all the
different pairs in a B so each sum here
each popular psalms contributes this
many times to a cross B so as a result
you know because size of a and size of B
are both at most n we find that the size
of s is at most 2k n and if you think
about what G is then this implies also
that the restricted subset of a and B
across this graph G which only requires
the popular sums so the restricted
subset is precisely the popular sums the
restricted subset is not too large
Oh
okay so we got one of the conditions so
that the restricted some set it's not
too large and now we want to show that
this graph has lots of edges that has
lots of edges and here's where we need
to use the hypothesis that between a and
B originally there's large additive
energy and the point here is that the
unpopular sums cannot contribute very
much to the additive energy in total
because each one of them is unpopular so
the dominant contributions to the
additive energy are going to come from
the popular sums and we're gonna use
that to show that G has lots of edges
okay so let's lower bound the number of
edges of G by first showing that we show
some contribute to energy between a and
B indeed the sums of the squares of the
ours for X not in popular sums is upper
bounded by claim that it is upper
bounded by the following quantity and
over two K times and squared because I
can take out one factor or upper bound
by this number just by definition and
the sums of the ours is
and squared so you have this additive
energy between a and B I know that it is
large by hypothesis whereas I also know
that I can write it as a sum of the
squares of these RS which I can break
into the popular contributions and the
unpopular contributions and hopefully
this should all be somewhat reminiscent
of basically all these proofs that we
did so far in this course where we
separate a sum into the dominant terms
and the minor terms this came up a
Fourier analysis in particular so we do
this splitting and we upper bound the
unpopular contributions by the estimate
from just now so as a result bringing
this small error term it doesn't cancel
much of the energy so we still have a
lower bound some of the squares of the
R's in the popular sums but I can also
give a fairly trivial upper bound to a
single are namely it cannot be bigger
than and
okay and so the number of edges of G
okay so what's the number of edges of G
look at that each X here contributes RX
many edges so the number of edges of G
is simply the sums of these are X's
which is quite large so the hypotheses
of graph PhD are satisfied and so we can
use the conclusion of graph psg which is
the conclusion that we're looking for in
BSG okay any questions so the remaining
task is to prove the graphical version
of BSG so let's take a quick break and
when we come back we'll focus on this
theorem and has some nice graph
theoretic arguments okay let's continue
we've reduced the proof of the pollak
similarity cowards theorem to the
following graphical result well it's not
just graphical right still we're still
inside some abelian group I still
looking at some sets in some appealing
group that's only now it has a craft
attached to it let me show this theorem
through several steps first something
called a path of length to lemon
so the path of length to lemon the
statement is that you start with a graph
G which is a bipartite graph between
vertex sets a and B and now it be no
longer need that they're just sets
they're just vertex sets we're not going
to have sums and the number of edges is
at least a constant fraction of the
maximum possible then the conclusion is
that there exists some you a subset of a
such that U is fairly large and between
most pairs of elements of U so between 1
minus epsilon fraction of pairs of you
there are lots of common neighbors so at
least epsilon delta squared B over 2
common neighbors
you have you start with this bipartite
graph a and B lots of edges and we would
like to show that there exists a pretty
large subset u such that between most
pairs whole button epsilon fraction of
ordered pairs there could be the same
but doesn't really matter the number of
paths of length to between these two
vertices is quite large so there are
lots of common neighbors where have we
seen something like this before
it's question so for every epsilon and
every Delta
where have we seen something like this
before so in the bipartite graph with
lots of edges I want to find a large
subset of one of the parts so that every
pair of elements or almost every pair of
elements have lots of common neighbors
dependent random choice so in very first
chapter of this course when we did
extremal graph theory forbidding
bipartite sub graphs there was a
technique for proving the extremal
number of her bounds for bipartite
graphs of bounded degree and there we
used something called dependent random
choice that had a conclusion that was
very similar flavor so there we had
every pair so a fairly large but not its
largest this a fairly large subset where
every pair of elements had lots of
common neighbors for every topple every
couple of vertices have lots of common
neighbors so it's very similar in fact
it's the same type of technique that
were use to prove this lemma over here
okay who remembers how to find em random
choice goals so the idea is that we are
going to choose you not uniformly at
random so that's not gonna work gonna
choose that in a dependent random way so
I want elements of you to have lots of
common neighbors typically so one way to
guarantee this is to choose you to be a
neighborhood from the right so pick a
random element in B and choose you to be
its neighborhood so let's do that
everything that course comes together so
let's pack be an element of be uniformly
at random and let you be the
neighbourhood so first of all by
linearity of expectations the size of
you yes at least Delta because the
average degree from the right from B
years at least Delta a just based on the
number of edges if you have two vertices
ain't a prime they worth a small number
of common neighbors then the size of a
prime have small number of common
neighbors then the probability that a a
prime both lie in you should be quite
small because if they both had if in a
prime have a small number of common
neighbors in word therefore in a prime
to be included in this you you must have
chosen okay so suppose this were their
common a bird then in water that in a
prime B containing you you must have
chosen this meat to be inside the common
neighborhood of a and a prime
which is unlikely if a a prime have a
small number of common neighbors so this
probability is at most epsilon delta
squared over two if you just think about
how u is constructed so if we let X be
the number of na Prime's
in you cross U with at most epsilon
Delta squared over 2 times B comma
neighbors then by linearity of
expectations the expectation of X is by
summing up all of these probabilities of
a and a prime both being in you so this
is at most epsilon delta squared over 2
times size of a squared so typically
that's at least an expectation you do
not expect very many pairs of elements
in you with few common neighbors but we
can also turn such an estimate into a
specific instance and the way to do this
is to consider the quantity size of nu
squared minus x over epsilon first of
all we can lower bound this quantity
because the side the second moment of U
is at least the first moment of U
squared and we also know that the size
of X in X minton x in expectation is not
very large so the whole expression can
be lower bounded by Delta
squared over 2 times size of a square
therefore there is some concrete
instance of this randomness resulting in
some specific u such that this
inequality holds so there exist some u
such that this inequality holds and in
particular we find that the size of U is
at least just forget about this minus
term it's at least the right hand side
square root so particular the size of us
at least Delta over two times the size
of a and just looking at the left hand
side which must be a non-negative
quantity because the right hand sign is
non-negative we find that X is at most
an epsilon fraction of U squared so
putting this together we arrive at the
path of length 2 lemma so let me go
through it again so this is the
dependent random choice method where we
want to find this u where most pairs of
vertices in you have lots of common
neighbors so we start from the right
side we start from B take a uniform
random vertex what you call V and let u
be the neighborhood of V and I claim
that this you typically should have the
desired property when the reason is that
if you have a pair of vertices on the
left that
have many common neighbors then I claim
it is highly unlikely that these two
vertices both appear in you because for
them to both appear in you your V must
have been selected inside become a
neighborhood of a and a prime which is
unlikely if aim a prime have few common
neighbors so as a result the expected
number of pairs in you with small number
of common neighbors is small and already
that's a very good indication that we're
on the right track and to finish things
off we look at this expression which we
can lower bound by convexity and we know
the size of U in the expectation is
large and also the size of X we just saw
is small in the expectation so you have
this inequality over here and because
there's an expectation it implies that
there's some specific instance such that
without the expectation the inequality
holds so take that specific instance we
obtain some u such that this inequality
is true which simultaneously implies
that U is large and X the number of bad
pairs is small so that was dependent
random choice any questions
all right so that was the path of length
to lemon house I can pick a large step
with lots of paths of length to between
most pairs of vertices let's upgrade
this lemma to a path of length 3 so in
the path of length 3 lemon we start with
a bipartite graph as before between a
and B G's bipartite between a B and as
before we have a lot of edges between a
and B it's the delta fraction of all
possible edges then the conclusion is
that there exists a prime in a and B
prime sub set of B such that a prime and
B prime are both large fractions of
their parent set and now the and
furthermore every pair between a prime
and D prime is joined by many paths of
length 3
a path of length three means there's
three edges and here this eita is
basically the original error term up to
a polynomial will change starting with
this bipartite graph that's fairly dense
the lemma tells us that we can find some
large a prime and large B prime so that
between every vertex in a prime and
every vertex in V Prime there are lots
of paths of length three between them
and okay so the way you should think
about all of these constants is flunks
you only make polynomial changes in the
constants we're having here eita
is polynomial change in the Delta
there's a convention which I like which
is non universal but it's often followed
and like this convention this the
difference between a little C in a big C
is that a little C it's better if you
make it smaller and the Big C is better
I mean it's better in the sense that if
this is true for little C and Big C and
you make little C smaller and Big C
bigger then it is still true so Big C is
a sufficiently large constant a little C
is a sufficiently small constant okay so
let's see the path of length three lemma
see it's proof we're going to use the
pattern length to lhamo but we need a
bit of preparation first so the proof
have some Nightside yes but it's also
some parts of it a slightly tedious so
bear with me so we're going to construct
a chain of subsets a inside a so a1 a2
a3 and this is just because there's a
few cleaning up steps that need to be
done let's call to vertices in a
friendly they have lots of common
neighbors and precisely we're going to
say they're friendly if they have more
than Delta squared over 80 times the
size of B common neighbors
let me construct this sequence of
subsets as follows first let a one be
all the vertices in a with degree not
too small so this is in preparation so
we'll make our life quite a bit easier
later on let's just trim all the really
small degree vertices so that we don't
have to think about them so you trim all
the small degree vertices and think
about how many edges you trim
you cannot trim so many edges because
each time you trim such a vertex you
only get rid of a small number of edges
so in the end at least half of the
original set of edges must remain and as
a result the size of a one is at least a
Delta over two fraction of the original
vertex set otherwise you cannot have
contained half of the original set of
edges ok so this is the first trimming
step so we got rid of some edges but we
got rid of fewer than half of the
original edges and because now you have
a minimum degree on a1 the number of
edges between a 1 and B is is quite
large still quite large so think about
passing down to a 1 now
in the second step we are going to apply
the path of length to lemma 2 this a 1
so a 2 is going to be constructed from
so using the path of length to lhamo
specifically with parameter epsilon
being Delta over 10 although remember
now the density of the graph went from
Delta to Delta over 2 again if you don't
care about the specific numbers they're
all polynomials in Delta so don't worry
about them everything is poly Delta so
we're going to apply the path of length
2 lemma to find this subset a 2 and it
has the property that a 2 is quite large
and oh but a small fraction of pairs and
a 2 are friendly
so we pass down to first
trimming small degree vertices and then
pass down further to a - we're open a
small fraction of elements in a 200 but
a small fraction of the pair's are
friendly to each other meaning they have
loss of common neighbors and now let's
look at the other side let's look at B
so we're in this situation now where you
have so we're we're now in a situation
where you pass down to a 2 and in B
where because of what we did initially
every vertex in here 1/2 large degree so
there's this minimum degree condition
from every vertex on the left so the
average degree is still very high as a
result the average degree from B there's
going to be quite high so let's focus on
the P side and pick out vertices in B
that have high degree so let P 1 denote
vertices be such that the degree from B
to a - yes
at least half of what you expect based
on average degree and as before the same
logic as the a1 step we see that p1 has
large size is a large fraction of B ok
now we pass down to this
be one set now finally let's consider a
three to be vertices in a tube where a
is friendly so vertices in a tube such a
a is friendly to at least one over Delta
over so 1 minus Delta over five fraction
so we saw that in a two most pairs of
vertices are friendly or so most meaning
about a delta over ten fraction so if we
consider vertices which are unfriendly
to many other vertices in a tube there
aren't so many of them if there are many
of them you couldn't have had that so
that's why I construct this set a three
consisting of elements in a two that are
friendly to many elements and the size
of a three there's at least half
okay so we have this a3 inside
alright now I claim that we can take a 3
and B as our final sets and between
every vertex in a3 and every vertex in
b1 I claimed there must be lots of paths
of length 3 but first let's check their
sizes so I mean the sizes all should be
okay because we never lost too much each
step if you only care about polynomial
factors or you already see that we never
lost anything more than a polynomial
factor but just to be precise the size
of a3 is at least also if you count up
the factor lost at each step so it's 1/2
Delta over 4 Delta over Q so it's at
least Delta squared over 16 fraction of
the original set 8 and now if we
consider a comma B to be an arbitrary
pair in a 3 cross B 1 I claim that there
must be many paths because by using okay
so what properties do we know we know
that B is adjacent to a large fraction
so here large means at least Delta over
4 so bounded below a large fraction of
yeah so I apologize when I say the word
large depending on context it could mean
like bigger than Delta or it could mean
at least 1 minus Delta so you look at
what I write down right so so B is
adjacent to at least Delta over 4
fraction of 82 at the same time we know
that a is friendly to at least one minus
Delta over 5 fraction of B to
okay so these two sets they must overlap
by at least Delta over twenty fraction
take a vertex so you Jason to many
vertices here and if you look at the
vertex in a and its friendly to a large
fractions in particular it is friendly
to all these elements over here so to
finish off what does it mean for a this
is this vertex is a this for Texas P
what does it mean for a to be friendly
to all of these shaded elements it means
that there are lots of paths from a to
each of these elements and then you can
finish off the path going back to be
no the shaded question says Shana stuff
allowed to be outside s we know the
shaded things are inside a stream so
we're looking at intersections within a
three no sir
you know you're right so the shaded
things can be outside a shady things can
be outside we apologize so everything
that was in a 2 so P is Jason to a large
fraction of a two and a here is friendly
to some part of neighbors of B so you
can complete path like that so only the
starting and ending point have to be in
a prime and B prime everything else they
can go outside of the a prime and B
Prime yeah thank you so the number the
number of paths from A to B to a - back
to so yes stay within p1 so is at least
so it's so it's at least Delta over 20
times a 2 times Delta over Delta squared
over 80 times B so if you don't care
about polynomial factors in Delta then
see that
pointless it's a large fraction of there
are a lot of paths there are a lot of
paths between each little a and each
it'll be by the construction we've done
okay so let me just do a recap so there
were quite a few details in this proof
someone don't have to do with cleaning
up because it's not so nice to work with
graphs that just have large average
degree it's much nicer to work with
graphs with large minimum degree so
there are a couple of steps here to take
care of vertices with small degrees
right so we started with between a and B
lots of edges and we trim vertices from
a with small degree so we get a 1 and
then we apply the pattern line to lemma
to get a 2 so inside a 2 most pairs of
vertices have loss of common neighbors
but not all we then go back to B to get
p1 which has large minimum degree to a 2
and then a 3 looks at vertices in a with
many friendly companions in a tube and a
3 is large and I claim that between
every vertex in a 3 and every vertex in
B you have many paths of length 3
because if you start with a vertex in a
3 it has many friendly companions okay
so many here means at least 1 minus
Delta over 5 fraction whereas every
vertex in B one has lots of neighbors in
a to wear lots means at least Delta over
4 so there's necessarily an overlap of
at least Delta over 20 and for that
overlap we can create lots of paths
going through this overlap from a
any questions okay great so let's put
everything together to prove the
graphical version of Pollock similarity
colors so we'll put the graphical
version of Pollock similar to ours so by
first note that the hypothesis of
Pollock's and where did ours already
implies that the size of a and the size
of B are not too small because otherwise
you couldn't have had and squared over K
edges to begin with so by the path of
length three lemma there exists a prime
in a and B prime B with the following
properties a prime is large fraction of
a prime and B prime both large in size
and for all vertices in a prime and
virtus B in B prime there are lots of
paths of length 3 between these vertices
so there are at least K to the minus
root all 1 to the minus bigger one times
n squared pairs of intermediate vertices
a1 b1
in a cross B such that a B 1 a 1 B
there's a path in G so let me draw the
situation for you so we have a B and so
inside a and B we have this fairly large
a prime and B prime such that for every
other way
little B there are many paths like that
going to be 1 a to let me set okay so
let me set X to be a plus B 1 that's
some Y to be a1 plus b1 and Z to be a 1
plus B all right
so now notice that we can write this a
plus B in at least K to the minus bigger
one times and squared ways as X minus y
plus Z by following this path where x y
and z all lie in the restricted subset
because that's how the restricted subset
is to find edge then the sum of the
elements across the two ends by
definition lies in the restricted subset
okay so the path of length 3 lemma tells
us that every pair a and B there's some
can be written in many different ways as
this combination as a result we see that
a prime plus B prime so this sum if we
consider some along with this
multiplicity so so now we're really
looking at all the different sums as
well as ways of writing this sum as as
this combination we see that it is
bounded above by
the restricted some set raised to the
third power
as each of these choices XY and Z they
come from the restricted subset but the
hypothesis of bollocks and where D
covers the graphical version is that the
restricted subset is small in size so we
can now upper bound the restricted
subset by basically the within F
constant within a factor of their
maximum possible and now we are done
because we have deduced that the
complete sum set between a prime and B
prime is at most a constant factor in
changing the constant by a polynomial or
constant factor more than the maximum
possible it's at most K to the bigger
one poly K times n but so that proves
the graphical version of our exam where
D cowers and because we showed earlier
that the graphical version of Ballack
similar D cowers implies public
similarity cowards that shows the
Pollack's America are still so let me
recap some of the ideas we saw today and
so the whole point of pollak somewhere
Deek hours and all of these related
lemmas and theorems and variations is
that you start with something that has a
lot of additive structure or after we
passed down to graphs just a lot of
edges so you start with a situation
where you have kind of 1% goodness and
you want to show that you can restrict
to fairly large subsets so that you have
perfection so you have complete goodness
between these two sets and this is
what's going on in both the graphical
version and the additive version so back
to the graph of path of length 3 lemma
so we were able to boost
the path of length to llama which tells
us something about 99% of the pair's
having loss of common neighbors to a
hundred percent of the Paris having loss
of path of length 3 and in the additive
setting we saw that if by starting with
a situation where the hypothesis is you
know somewhat patchy I said like 1
percent type hypothesis we can pass down
to a fairly large sets where the
complete sum set starting with just the
restricted subset being small you can
pass down to large sets where the
complete sum set is small and this is an
important principle that often when we
have some typicality by an appropriate
argument and here's you know it's not at
all trivial argument so there's some
cleverness involved but by doing some
kind of argument we may be able to pass
downn to some fairly large set where
it's not typically good but everything
is perfectly good
and that's the spirit here of the pollak
similarity cowards theorem so next time
for the last lecture of this course I
will tell you about the sum-product
problem where the there also some graph
very nice graph thematic inputs